oh I had to take a deep breath look
listen uh I know that uh you guys want
to always get right into the show I just
asked for two minutes of your time here
you can set the uh the timer last week
made the announcement here that of
course we are moving on from The Blaze
life is a series of meetings and
partings uh and to stay in touch I asked
you to sign up at mugclub forever.com
that is still the best way right now if
you have not done it yet mugclub
forever.com enter in only enter in your
email if you are in or want to be in my
club no spam there's not going to be a
newsletter there's not going to be a
merch shop plugs in there it is just for
when and where mug Club launches again
later with crowded just to be clear so
uh so many of you to give you an update
signed up
that our mail service even locked the
account it's okay we're fine we have
your emails they thought this was too
fast this couldn't be happening after
that we were hit with some DDOS attacks
we added a capture code so if you see it
we may end up sending you a confirmation
email
if you just want to be safe please sign
up again at Mud clubforever.com but
there's something else here too emails
are not necessarily the safest way or
the only way they go to spam sometimes
you don't open them sometimes you have
an aggressive filter this information
Wasteland that is the internet it is
always hard to stay in touch with people
so of course look you can sign up just
search the show on any social media to
stay updated but the second best way I
have one request of you today
uh the audio feed the podcast where we
broadcast you know Apple spotify android
a couple months ago broke somehow uh we
lost touch with a lot of you the best
thing you can do sign up for the email
but subscribe to the audio podcast now I
need to clear I hate doing the inside
baseball here but this is super
important just give me 30 more seconds
I'm not able to see subscribers on audio
the way it works we can only see plays
on the show that lets us know how many
of you are subscribed and it
automatically downloads to your phone so
to confirm that you have subscribed
right this is a roundabout way because
I'm clever like that right now and by
clever I mean
passable right now I have released on
the audio stream whether it's Spotify
Apple Android Google Play wherever you
are this it's currently available hold
on pause hold on pause this
61 second test pattern
Joe Lewis is a fire siren
[Music]
it is not an FCC violation because it's
not a real test pattern just to be clear
go to wherever you are on audio play
that test pattern and subscribe that way
I know that I can reach as a matter of
fact during this break
I may just release some exclusive audio
that's the easiest place for me to
release audio as we figure things out so
many of you have joined and entered in
your email this goes beyond mug Club
we're talking about
something a lot bigger at this point and
because of some issues outside of my
control can't do it right away so the
easiest thing is maybe for me to do some
audio Puck I may do some of those if
you're looking for some updates while
I'm on the road I'll still be on the
road lotto's cutter.com will be doing
stand up I'll be announcing dates as we
figure this out so again sign up at
mugclub forever.com And subscribe to the
audio podcast if you are not already
just play that 61 second test pattern
and we know that we can reach you on
with the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
father
s
[Music]
oh delicious delicious a very very busy
weekend
uh and as I told you today is going to
be a little bit of a shorter show here
on YouTube because
we want to tell you all the things that
we can't say on YouTube So today we're
going exclusively to mugler we'll be
talking about
well that's part of the plan right my
club forever in the future that none of
that matters so you can sign up there so
today is you can't say that on YouTube
you don't hit the Stinger tool man it's
okay he's so overly he's ready
he's so overly equal I gotta fix my
headphones he's so overlay here with the
button there uh so what we will be
talking about today is a couple of
updates JK Rowling uh obviously Elon
Musk drops some Twitter files we'll be
talking about that behind the table
we'll be talking about the vaccine we'll
be talking about elections things like
that so I do have a question for you
after the people on Elon Musk uh have
taken the poll and favored him stepping
down do you think he'll do it
who could replace him
who should replace him nobody comment
like share Rumble all of that because
the algorithms right now they help us
reach everybody to let you know about uh
you know where we'll be going with Mud
Club you can hit those so you can be
generous with those Tool Man be polite
okay that's another rule
[Music]
always be polite
right really quickly I will introduce uh
Dave Landau is not here right now you
can go to Daylight davelandow.com
hopefully he had people at Syracuse last
week and they got snowed in oh really
yeah it was huge snow but uh between New
Year's and Christmas he's somewhere in
Ohio go to davelandow.com I don't have
it in front of me I think it's Toledo is
it Toledo okay so that's Gerald a you
hear him how are you sir I'm doing well
how are you busy busy busy yes we are
baby and then we have in search here
today I never called them this crawdaddy
how are you he's never used the term no
I've always said pops Crowder I think
Syracuse snow is deeper than Dave Lando
he has to walk around with a fishing
pole tied to his shoulder lag up there
oh right so we have so much to get hey
show him a Superman there oh show them
Superman I was forced to yes that is one
thing people have been asking
crowdershop.com that's still of course
always goes to us and of course uh as
I'll be touring their pardon our dust
but before we get on to the news
um in what is developed over the weekend
I guess in other breaking news Argentina
has the world's best gaze
[Applause]
see naked
[Applause]
no sorry I didn't mean that I didn't
mean that was the gayest thing I meant I
meant this no sorry I meant this this or
this or this or I think this
yeah by the way none of those people
were touched no none of those people
were touched the wind blew
you used to like soccer don't try and
play like hipster now like I just liked
it before it's popular no listen I do
like song I still like soccer I hate
that component of soccer and so do most
soccer fans they need to clean it up
right they hate it so much that they
watch it in record numbers unless
they're women they do watching record
numbers I even tweeted out about it I
was like we they seem more interested in
flopping than actually scoring goals
that team lost by the way so I was like
yes well we watched we watched it
because we have some South American
friends and daddy we watched it it was
it was a guy who played hockey who
played hockey um hard to watch yeah and
the stands were empty Gerald no they
weren't yes they were oh yes I don't
know if that's where the Sheiks go in
Qatar and they they kept it open which
game did you guys watch the final yeah
I would be willing to that every time
I would bet substantially more than a
dollar that most of the stands were
empty we just don't know if it was for
cutar whatever Clock Boys family I have
no idea why they were so empty and we
all have to act like we care about this
sport do you like soccer honestly
football if you want to do that look
only when it's tough guys and there's
very few of them
you mispronounced none none crud edit
you were watching right now it's hard I
was watching a fight that same night or
the night before Sean Strickland versus
Jared Cannon here he took 20 leg kicks
in a round a guy gets a little bit of a
cleat to the shiny
hey who am I and then and he gets up and
he goes and then he's right back in the
game well it's so funny because if they
get the penalty immediately they're fine
if they yes they'll roll around for a
minute and a half and look up every once
in a while like a five-year-old to see
if you're actually playing along yeah
does just I'm saying a sport shouldn't
encourage acting because it should not
and guys go down all over the field they
do nothing but when there's a whistle
they'll writhe in pain until there's a
decision oh it's terrible why don't they
Institute a rule where if you writhe in
pain you have to go off the field they
do so they have a simulation rule where
you can actually get penalized for that
but they just don't call it enough where
you're simulating an act like a a
penalty and it's like no no you got to
call that you just throw them out of the
game like it sucks it's a game that now
includes role playing pretty much and
none of us that have done played any any
contact Sports want anyone to play
injured we're not asking them to do that
but really guys it's going to be a pansy
either either get off got a whisker rub
[Laughter]
belly
it was a three-day beard when we go when
we go to mug Club yeah exactly guys pull
up just search worst flops in soccer
history they're simple we can't play
because FIFA is also really gay epic and
like nobody even comes close to some of
these people they go down like they got
shot from the stands I know you were
watching it going like oh gosh just Joe
Lewis left the room he was ashamed yes
he was yes
one guy was moaning so much he did his
fire Sam
by the way you go listen to that test
pattern of course on audio I'll play it
again this is yeah play it again you can
get 61 seconds right now if you're
epic there he goes
he's breaking some federal regulations
there for sure and for people who say oh
it's because it does not hurt his ears
it's not what's going on he loves doing
it he will chase fire trucks and do it
he was happy doing it yeah I'm so happy
doing it he scared the hell out of a
lady one time because it was pitched
like he's a nice dog and she was petting
him and as she was petting him a fire I
could hear the fire truck in the
distance oh no but his whole body tenses
up
he's on a Brazilian talent show
[Laughter]
absolutely he's already been neutered
it's better he's more in Rhythm and you
know beat I don't know the music stuff
we weren't gonna find you Mr Crowder
until we realized your dog was Pitch
Perfect yes
and you wonder where I get it so
uh we'll take some chats from you here
actually in front of the in just here on
YouTube but just so you know if you're
watching today anywhere we are going to
mug Club exclusive to get into all the
stuff that we couldn't say on YouTube uh
for the year just to round it out and of
course we have our Christmas show
Wednesday just so you know how to dry in
the room Wednesday we had to pre-tape it
because I do the the Santa Crowder and
we give away a lot of checks to some
families in need there's a family that
uh lost a child and and I I can't
imagine anything uh anything tougher and
um it feels good to be able to give back
you know you did that with hurricane
Harvey you did that with a scholarship
and officer David dorton's name he did
it last year we supplied uh everything
that people want our families need toys
gifts uh food
um shelter I think for some people and
this year we were able to help a lot of
people and that's entirely because of
you over there at my club do we have a
oh we do okay so you know what so this
is going to be Wednesday and by the way
I do encourage you to watch this because
a lot of the times people say hey we
want something non-political we want
some this is just
hopefully spreading a little bit of the
Christmas spirit which is what everyone
is supposed to be about at this point in
time it's not a hot take I get it
there's nothing controversial it's just
giving back because you've given to us
you can enjoy this Wednesday
well Merry Christmas we do this here
every year at the ladder with Crowder
program let's deliver some Christmas Joy
it's time for my favorite part in
Crowder gives back Santa is going to be
sending you a check for fifty thousand
dollars to help with Gracie and anything
that you need here for the rest of the
year to help you reset
and to help your family as you get
through this Christmas season
[Music]
we'll see you
when we see you
yeah we tip that on Friday just so you
know I drove home crying like a [ __ ]
a bunch of cry babies in the studio you
yes you were crying I know but
I'll bring over the Kyle Rittenhouse
verdict we all were oh yeah that's true
I was blubbering because I've seen his
new Dame
one for you Kyle you saw say boy so
now I'm sounding like a soccer player a
little bit sausage
I think of things that are entirely
reasonable JK Rowling has found herself
in the uh in the cross uh trans chest
hairs of the left after she funded from
her own biological uh wait hold on a
second let me get this right from her
own pocket yes a biological women only
rape help center in Scotland no just so
you know these uh used to be known as
rape help centers
now this has been met with a lot of
backlash the shelter uh and it's called
bearer's place is only going to be
serving
um you know uh CIS females females naria
penis to be found right right okay hair
yes Nary Harry Harry
I just watched it last night yeah I
watched I watched the nine series of
murders in Home Alone 2 last night
my gosh that would leave looking like
the Elephant Man yeah
deformed so uh of course look this would
seem like someone we could all be on
board with right
no Twitter trolls weren't happy not only
Twitter Trolls but more importantly
reporters legitimate Publications are
mad about a woman funding a rape help
center out of her own pocket uh here you
have queer sassy said this excluding
trans women from a women's only service
is no more okay than excluding lesbian
women women of color or women with
disabilities well first off if it was a
lesbian woman like a battered lesbian
women shelter you just you just wouldn't
have the capacity you couldn't be
beating each other up highest domestic
abuse rate of any demographic so no more
okay than including lesbian women women
of color or women with disabilities
there's no such thing as sex-based
rights notice I didn't say gender just
how there's no ethnicity based rights
that's the point of equality no it's not
you know what she tries to do something
good she's got this in her past JK
Rowling right she's trying to do
something good in Edinburgh she sets it
up pays from her pocket this is not a
charity she doesn't even get the tax
write-off for this she takes no
donations for this as we know so far and
people are like well that's not
inclusive enough that's not good enough
that you're trying to make a difference
because you don't want anybody to come
in there looking like they maybe they
haven't fully transitioned and a woman
is in there because she's been sexually
assaulted and sees somebody coming in
the door that looks like maybe one of
her attackers but I'm not saying a trans
person attacked I'm just saying somebody
who might still look more like a man
than a woman there has never been a
smaller Fringe minority group of people
who have more access to everything than
right now the transgender movement
imagine if imagine if uh gun owners
could mobilize this effectively she's
just think about that for a second
there's literally right now a movement a
protest to get into a safe space for
women who've been raped
and it's a problem
they claim it's a civil rights issue a
human rights issue imagine if imagine if
you know freedom of speech Advocates
Second Amendment advocates for crying
out loud your right to privacy if all of
you could mobilize as effectively as
biological males who've transitioned to
women want to take a dump at Target
so here's the nurse she's going to run a
rape kit on you but oh my God
for that
well good for good for JK oh my God
and comment below I changed the name but
it's the principle is the same it works
so on Sunday a transgamer by the handle
of Jesse gender
okay
piled on the Rowling hate train uh this
is this is what uh this person said uh
uh I will not begrudge anyone their love
of past works or thing that's misspelled
obviously they already own that they
take comfort in I own the first nine
movies and all seven books myself but
any support of something like Hogwarts
Legacy I believe is a new video game is
harmful so JK Rowling responded to that
saying Jesse gender I'm deeply
disappointed Jesse dinner doesn't
realize pure think is incompatible with
owning anything connected with me in any
form the truly righteous wouldn't just
burn their books and movies but the
local library anything with an owl on it
and their own pet dogs hashtag do better
now here's the thing
there's just a few Twitter people okay
and by the way JK Rowling is not a
conservative she's not right-wing in any
capacity at all just to be clear just
believes that if you you know have a
penis and testicles that you're not that
you're not a woman that's all shocker
that you're not a female
I know we're a little bit confused
because Admiral Levine first four star
female it's bull crap just don't buy the
rules that gender and sex are separate
they don't even they don't even believe
in themselves this is what they write
when they're at this point when they
come to that that impasse uh you know it
really is the same we want to have
access to everything because it's Sports
remember early on well we're not talking
about sports we're about gender is
separate that's biological sex well here
we are now oh no we're not talking about
like biological women's only Spirit
we're not talking about you know like
pregnancy tests well that's where we are
right now so the impartial journalists
at Forbes
had this to say about the exchange JK
Rowling author of the Harry Potter
series has become the most prominent
face and voice in the world of
anti-trans rhetoric where she anti-trans
rhetoric by opening up a rape Center for
Women
and sentence
Every Good Deed that goes unpunished
right no no good deed goes unpunished in
her case every good deed goes punished
punished do you want to restate it for
the for the jury no good deed goes
unpunished Every Good Deed from JK
Rowling goes punished that's why I love
you is punished it's punished it's
punishing completely privately funded
yes I mean yes it's just like they're
just sending marriage you know the
marriage equal don't you just love how
they compare race to gender to sexual
preference gosh people who actually push
for you know black people in this
country were discriminated against who
push for inter you guys have you've got
n gals have got to be pissed pissed but
by the way I'm I'm struggling kind of
with the procession here um if if a man
horrible person rapist tries to rape a
transgender person who when he gets down
to the business of it's terrible in a
total hypothetical scenario that has
never happened of course there would
never be a woman at this rape center for
example who maybe was sexually assaulted
or harassed by a trans
yeah it never happened in the history of
man what I'm saying is when he gets down
to the undercarriage and sees that the
parts aren't compatible to what he
thought was going to be there doesn't
want they typically I mean what do how
do they continue on what are you asking
me Gerald I'm so confused if you've got
sword fighting going on there like stuff
wouldn't uh wouldn't a rapist who's
trying to rape somebody who looks like a
woman and finds out she's not a woman
wouldn't he probably rethink I mean he's
not going to be like well I got this far
I don't know about if they're gonna
think
so here's the fact he's still a crime
you're the facts by the way on JK
Rowling Jake only not conservative at
all just to be clear uh she has an
unbelievable
history of Leaning left so including by
the way making her characters more
inclusive more diverse Hermione is now
black now I don't have a problem with
that I'm not saying he's black because I
don't care I'm an adult I don't watch
those movies but
made Dumbledore and more offensive
Dumbledore played by Jude Law who by the
way could could make a lot of straight
men question themselves but she even
made Dumbledore gay
when I was young I was committed to me
to us
I went along because
because I was in love with you
then they role played as the prisoners
of Azkaban
you should have seen where they stuffed
Toby
just put me under the stars
help it's covered us look the point
isn't okay Dumbledore's gay Hermione's
black and she's like and you know I just
think that women should have a space you
know uh because look look let's just go
through the left always talks about you
know they use the term trigger warning
okay trigger warning being triggered is
an actual psychological term and I hate
that it's sort of been used
because there are people for example
very tough guys coming back from war
Marines were their PTSD can actually be
triggered right from a traumatic event
if your traumatic event involves being
sexually assaulted right with the tool
primarily being used a penis it would
make sense that you wouldn't want
penises around these women when they
require safe space it's fair that would
be a legitimate trigger a penis trigger
so no penises
it would seem like a reasonable policy
but that's me Mr old-fashioned
and in light of uh of course the
anti-trans comments unfortunately this
is why you don't bend the knee to the
Mob Rowling's latest adjustment does
seem a little bit I I think it might be
tongue-in-cheek if it is it's
mean-spirited uh Rowling announced that
she'll be remaking the entire Harry
Potter series and that the role of
Voldemort now will be cast uh as Caitlyn
Jenner so that is yeah
[Laughter]
my name
pretty good uh Caitlyn Jenner daddy you
forced me to dress that way no that was
believable that was passable Governor
sir Caitlyn Jenner my size 13 Triple H
oh yeah you chose to make it the Sharon
Stone Caitlyn Jenner that was your call
anyone needs some Alaskan king crab
crack
it's a woman of the year crab cracker
so probably the most incredible athlete
of the 70s I know so amazing she won
those gold medals you know what a woman
and a sea of men she blew past that
glass ceiling
I don't think that's how it works but
okay that is how it works fine Ella
here's the thing it doesn't work
consistently at all Caitlyn Jenner
didn't win a medal but Elliott page has
all the IMDb credits
how is any of this consistent so how
about this you want until you figure it
out
a rape a rape a a rape kit and of course
a rape center or a battered women's
shelter should be for biological females
how about that until you figure it out
until everything is consistent Caitlyn
Jenner has the medals just like Elliot
page has the IMDb credits until
everything lines up and is consistently
addressed okay there need to be places
for for women only and by the way for
men only the only problem is there's no
male Cur there's no men's curves it just
I mean just becomes a fouchy bath house
there's no way to do men only spaces
these days without it just getting away
from you it could be or it could be
whatever the Argentina soccer club that
way well I wouldn't call those men no so
uh all right uh let's take a couple of
let's take a chat or two uh and by the
way again uh if you did enter your email
I would ask that you entered in again
just for just for security right having
redundancies helps at mugclub
forever.com
uh and we'll get let's take a chat uh
first and then we'll get back to that
okay yeah so we asked this uh last show
but we're getting a ton of repeat
questions so I just wanted to put it out
there again chicken Strangler and
someone named Christo y both want to
know where are all the old videos going
to be available for future viewing I'm
letting my Blaze expire but will old
episodes Ben content transferred to the
new location when it started yeah so
look we're going to have uh obviously we
have the episodes wherever mug Club ends
up being uh when where and if and again
this is why you're setting up at mugglib
forever.com I say Michael but of course
louder with Crowder and on YouTube
nothing's changing so just just to be
clear on the
newsletter maybe hold on a second no
yeah no if you go to mugclub forever.com
just to be clear do not enter in your
email unless you are in or want to sign
up for mug Club when it relaunches along
with whatever may be included in that so
no it's not it's not a newsletter not a
news okay yeah this is not a merch or
anything no no no no no no no no no no
do not enter your email in at mugclub
forever.com to be clear
unless you are in yes just for mug Club
when it relaunches louder with Crowder
and people who want the additional hours
Crowder Crowder bits
no no it's not quite a bit so it's not
quite a bit it's if mugclub forever.com
you're not getting anything there there
will be no other emails there might be
one confirmation email to make sure
you're not a robot it is just for people
who are in or ready to be in mug club
and look this is going to tell us how
big we do it and the scope of what it is
that we do live shows like nothing
nothing
mugclub forever.com and go to the Audio
One Last Time listen to the hit the 61
second test signal so we know you're
subscribed on audio
okay and I hate to I hate to like be
redundant with these plugs but you know
the way the internet is some of you are
on Instagram some of you are on Twitter
some of you so the email is the best
place and then audio I may do some
things while I'm on the road uh during
this time look don't know it's not going
to be very long but it's going to take a
little bit of time and now because of
where we are this week and we just want
to hit the purge button yeah just a
little bit it's time to uh uh it's time
to to go off YouTube and and let's let's
do the segment you can't say that on
YouTube
[Music]
oh okay all right so let's start talking
about no no no no no no no Stephen
you're still on YouTube Don't Wait don't
don't say anything no no no no no no no
[Music]
thank you